This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. New school year, same beautiful mess. Good Mom's Bad Choices is back to talk back to school realness. The guilt, the giggles, and the choices no other show is brave enough to admit. Mom Life is calling, and I have my last mother fucking volleyball tournament of Irie's club team volleyball. And I can't wait for the to be over. because I don't like participating and having to drive far distances.
Shout out to the moms and my mom who made it happen. Listen to Good Mom's Bad Choices from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. We've all been there. We've had seasons that have shaken everything. The question is, what remains when the shaking stops? Hi, I'm Gary Valenzheno. And on my podcast, Unshaken with Gary Vee, I sit down with amazing personalities and we talk about the seasons that nearly broke them, the lows that carried them to their highs.
Listen to Unshaken with Gary V on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hi, I'm Dr. James Stout. You might know me as a host of the podcast it could happen here. But I'm hosting a brand new show now called Natural Causes, where we explain how going outside is political, and look at how we can live together with nature and take care of one another in a world that's on fire. You know, we feel uncomfortable saying something like culture in wildlife, but that's what it is.
We're going to explain how a tick can make you sick and how a lizard might be able to help you and what mountain lines can teach us about zombie deer. You can see the very faint outmight into the Aurora. What a magical place. Listen to Natural Causes on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello, my love.
I'm Ryan Weiss, and for the past 15 years, I've been an emotional intelligence coach and a spiritual guide, and I'm sharing with you my new podcast, Waking Up with Ryan. Waking Up with Ryan is a daily audio video podcast, here to help you connect with yourself
before the noise of the day takes over. So let's start our days together with a moment of calm that's just for you. Listen to Waking Up with Ryan on the IHeart Radio, app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you are tired of listening to opinions without practical solutions, the Teslin Figaro podcast is a training room, not another commentary show.
I'm Teslin Figaro. As an award-winning business owner, political strategist, trainer, and jurors-docted candidate, every episode breaks down the law, politics, media, leadership, into practical strategies you can use in your everyday life. You have an additional footprint. You need to be aware because it can help you catch a case or can help you catch a case in your household. Listen to the Tesla and Figaro podcast.
from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s. Apologies in advance. Got it really croaked then. My voice is kind of bad. I have been sick and then also decided to kind of go out boogie-bugying last night.
And I don't know what it was. I wasn't singing. I think I'm just dehydrated, but she's croaky. So I'm sorry if you're one of those people who hates the sound of like, what do they call it vocal? what is it called vocal fry. I feel like I'm really giving vocal fry today, but it shouldn't detract too much from the content. I have a special bonus episode for you guys today. If you are not familiar with these bonus episodes, we've been doing it for perhaps the last
year or so. And these are kind of more bite-sized episodes where we take a popular psychology term, a phrase, a concept, a theory. And we've been, break it down for you and we reveal what it really means, what it's actually about. Basically, we myth bust some common psychological ideas that you probably see online that maybe have lost their original meaning. But we also get into the deeper history of these terms, how they came to be so popular and also some fun, you know, also less than fun facts that come along with them. Today, we have a very interesting one. I do want to give you a heads up though, this episode does include some details about violence and domestic violence.
So if that's something that you aren't particularly interested in hearing about or you're sensitive to, I would probably skip this one. It's not too much detail, but we definitely mention it. We are talking about Stockholm syndrome. I think these days when we use the term Stockholm Syndrome, it's often quite colloquial and quite casually, normally in reference to a situation where someone has kind of fallen in love or become very loyal to someone or something that they shouldn't be loyal to or which is harming them. Normally in regards to love, there is a very famous One Direction song of the same name where they basically just sing about being intoxicated by this girl, you know, they're obsessed with her, they long for her, they've got Stockholm syndrome.
It is so much more than that. And it's a lot more serious than that as well. It's not about obsession. It's not about intoxication. It's actually very much about survival. So Stockholm syndrome in a psychological sense, in a forensic sense, is a term used to describe what we would call a paradoxical emotional bond that forms between a victim and someone who, you know, who is threatening, harming, controlling, or holding them captive. That might include having positive feelings towards a captor or an abuser, having sympathy for their perspective, feeling gratitude for small acts of kindness against maybe a broader backdrop of unkindness,
fear and distrust of people who are trying to intervene and get you away from this person. Basically, any feeling or reaction that we kind of see as being irrational or counterintuitive towards somebody who means you harm is causing you harm and yet people feel a sense of loyalty to them or a sense of an emotional bond to them for strange reasons, but also less than strange reasons as we'll get into. From the outside, the reason why we call it a paradoxical emotional bond is because, as I said, you know, it kind of goes against how we think people should react in situations like this. We have this idea that if somebody is hurting you, you wouldn't want to be around that person.
If somebody is holding you captive, you're not going to have positive feelings towards them because they've taken away your agency and your independence and your privacy and your freedom. So shouldn't you have bad feelings about that person? Shouldn't you hate that person? And most importantly, shouldn't you want to escape the? that person shouldn't you want to take any opportunity offered to you to get away from them? The thing is, this isn't always the case. And it's not that these people are choosing or siding with an abuser or a person who holds power over them.
Stockholm syndrome is a survival strategy that forms under conditions where a person has so little choice and is experiencing such an extreme situation, a once-in-a-lifetime kind of stress, that they act in the only way they see is available to them to survive. And in that situation, the way they do that is by forming an emotional bond, by perhaps having sympathy, seeing their captor or their abuser as human as a way to connect with them. So the term first came from a very real hostage situation, in Sweden in 1973. It was a bank robbery at a credit bunkin in Stockholm, and it involved two captives and four employees, and they were held hostage for six days. Now, what made the case so
famous was not the robbery, although that definitely made headlines. It was what happened afterwards. Some of the captives, you know, as they were being rescued, almost seemed to fear the police more than the men who were holding them hostage. They seemed to have sympathy for these men. There was one hostage in particular, her name was Kristen Enmark, who essentially very much felt sorry for her captors, very much criticized aspects of the police response,
even went on to raise money for the legal defences of her captors, and their captors refused to testify, said they trusted them fully. And this confusing reaction really caught, the attention of psychiatrists and forensic psychologists who was seeing this way of responding as pretty counterintuitive, but also very interesting. They wanted to know kind of what happened in that situation, what happened in that bank that had turned these people so quickly into seemingly allies of the people who were harming them and holding them captive. And that's where they got the
term Stockholm syndrome to refer to these four people. And what they saw as kind of like almost a medical condition or a medical reaction, a psychological reaction, they had to this event. This is a very simplified telling of the story. You know, we could spend two hours going moment by moment about what happened and diving more into the outcomes and what happened afterwards. But it was the first time that this experience had a name. Another famous case is that of Patty Hurst, you may have heard about this. Hurst was a 19-year-old American actress. She was the granddaughter of a very famous newspaper publisher and politician at the time.
His name was William Randolph Hurst. She was kidnapped from her apartment in 1974 by a Liberation Army group. They were a radical political group. And during her captivity, these videos came out, these recordings came out of her criticizing her family, rejecting her family. rejecting her family. She even adopted the name, Tanya. She was seen taking part in a bank robbery with members of the group where she herself would have had an opportunity to escape. And she was arrested. She was not rescued. She was arrested and put on trial for assisting them in crimes. And her defense
argued that she had this rare thing. She had Stockholm syndrome. She'd been coerced. She'd been deeply, psychologically affected by captivity. And the jury saw the evidence and said, no, we're still going to convict you. So they didn't believe it. But now I think we definitely see it a little bit differently. We see what was a very young girl in a very stressful situation where she didn't feel safe. The only people she could trust were these people who, you know, essentially meant her harm. But they were the only ones there.
And she kind of fell into a relationship almost with them. So I've kind of been not referring to this as a mental health diagnosis. I don't know if you've noticed that, but for a reason, because it isn't. It still isn't accepted as, I guess it still isn't accepted as, yeah, just as a medical diagnosis. It isn't included in the DSM. There are no universally agreed upon diagnostic criteria. Stockholm syndrome is mainly just a descriptive label because it's,
It's also incredibly rare. Firstly, you know, it's incredibly rare for people to be held hostage for extended periods of time and to make it out alive. And in those situations, only about 8% of people, according to FBI analysis, exhibit what we would call Stockholm Syndrome. So of, you know, 1,200 hostage situations that they looked at, of those that had a surviving person, 8%. 8% of people were kind of experiencing even just a level of sympathy, loyalty, care, trust for their captors. There's another often discussed case in
relation to Stockholm syndrome. This woman called Natasha Kampushk. She was kidnapped in Austria. She was 10. She was held captive for eight years. And then she is, escaped in 2006 and there's a movie about her. And after her escape, obviously she's going through such an incredibly stressful period of time in her life and just probably one of the most stressful things you can experience as a human to be kidnapped, then to form a relationship with this person, then to be rescued. And the media really grabbed on some facts of this case and were like, she feels empathy for him. She forgives him. She look at this strange girl. She loves him. Like they were saying all these awful things. And this is again where Stockholm syndrome came back
into the limelight. And she herself, Natasha, has been really critical of the label Stockholm syndrome. She says that it can take power away from victims by implying that they, you know, choose this reaction, that something is wrong with them, that they're weak, that they have this syndrome that's affected their brain. She really says, you have no idea what this is. like until you are in the situation. This isn't a choice. This is a survival strategy. You know, if someone has spent years trapped with an abuser, learning how to read them, manage them, reduce harm, preserve some sense of psychological stability, like, that's kind of all you really have. All you are looking for is information, information that lets somebody stay alive.
And sometimes seeing your captor or seeing somebody as human is the smartest thing you can do in that situation so that you can gain better access to their mind and how they work and why or when they might be willing to let you go or show you kindness. So with that being said, what's actually going on here? What are the psychological mechanisms that create this kind of effect? Radio experience with Cameron Wickham live at the Riemann. With flights and two nights in Nashville to see Cameron Wickham at the legendary Riemann Auditorium. Plus a thousand dollar spending cash. Just listen to Pure Country for 10 minutes a day on the free IHart Radio app,
and you're in to win. Cameron Wilcom. Stream the new single, Kingdom of Fear. Available now. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. Every episode we're trying to help our guests improve their careers
by mainly focusing on how they can help us improve our careers. The show is famously super accessible, so you can easily jump into any of our 650 episodes. understand what's going on. We recommend some of our recent episodes with Ben Stillard. The definition of what is a movie has kind of changed anywhere too, right? What do you think it is now? It's images and words being spoken, captured by some sort of technology. Danny McBride. He loves Nova. Oh, that's fantastic. And you make it on, you make your own. That's great. I call him Terro Reed. It's a good name. They're all named after cast members of American Pie. Yeah.
Oh, gotcha. I call, I don't, I never looked up if she was in this, but I call him Leachie Sobieski. Yeah, I don't think she was an American pie, but I still like that. Haven't looked it up. Haven't looked it up. She was prominent around the same time. Yeah. Then Mary Steenberg.
Why are you guys talking to me? I'm worried. I'm worried. Why are you talking so down to me that you think I don't understand your little play game? I just really. I get it. I'm trying to set you up for success here. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
wherever you get your podcasts. On Solita, we share the messy stories of traveling alone as a woman. Your duolingo is not going to come back to you when a man is inside of you. Oh, no. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people, and they were like, you smiled at us.
Not a lot of people smile around here. I can wait four hours for the next bus, or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is, and not the lies you're sold about it. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first trip, I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you're you got your podcasts. I'm Nick Totoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue,
the longest yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Tatourl, I deliver pizza from Prince Street pizza to a new guest.
Are you delivering pizza now? Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone, from Seth Rollins. What are you doing my belt? To Alex Rodriguez. Just to let you people know, we're talking to one of the goats here.
To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness. Delivering Happiness. Mariano Rivera. Oh, my God. And many, many more.
Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Totoro. And listen now. I'm Hoda Kotmi, host of the podcast Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. If you know me, you know, I'm always searching for inspiration. and useful tools to maximize joy. So this podcast lets us uncover those things together through meaningful conversations with fascinating people. Like when my friend Henry Winkler offered advice to aspiring actors and really anybody hoping to stand out. You're not hired just to fill
time and space. You're hired to fill the space with you. You have something in your guts. You go with it. And Sean Johnson recalled the moment she realized her now husband, Andrew, was the one. He was just so unapologetically himself and knew nothing of Hollywood. He hadn't been on a plane before without his family. It was so pure. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. One way to understand Stockholm Syndrome is through our nervous system and how it responds to threats. We often talk about fight, flight, and freeze,
but there is also a fourth reaction that we commonly call fawning, like fawn, F-A-W-N. The basic idea is that if fighting somebody is useless or dangerous, if fleeing somebody is impossible, and if freezing doesn't end a threat, we, the final option we have available to us is to move towards pleasing, placating, reading the room, reducing the risk of escalation, and perhaps even trying to convince this person, hey, look, I'm your friend, don't hurt me. You know, imagine being physically,
psychologically, emotionally, socially trapped with someone who can hurt you. Your brain's primary function in that moment isn't going to be to produce a balanced moral analysis of, is this person deserving of sympathy or not? Should this person, should I be kind to this person or not, like it's not going through this shouldn't I, should I situation. It's just like, what is going to keep us alive? So it might be that you become tuned into their mood. It might be that you start to really notice, are they irritated, are they calm? What tone of voice should I use with them? Should I agree with what they say? Should I smile at them? Should I stay quiet? Should I act like a friend? That hyperattunement, maybe from the outside, looks like closeness, can start to feel like closeness.
or like a relationship, but it is basically a way to monitor threat and to get through this however one can. Researchers from the University of Queensland actually describe this through the idea of traumatic entrapment and appeasement. Their argument is that when a person is trapped with a more powerful aggressor, and that could be a partner, a criminal, a family member, even a really awful, cruel boss, appeasement can become a crucial survival strategy. if not the only survival strategy. More recently in a 2023 paper, so yeah, quite recent, researchers have actually argued that the term appeasement may be more accurate
and have less of a victim-blaming tone than Stockholm syndrome because it focuses on what the person is doing to survive rather than implying that they had a choice, rather than implying that what this thing was was a relationship. No, it's something else, it's something, it is, something else entirely. Another mechanism at play here is when fear is transposed into gratitude, if someone threatens your life but then chooses not to harm you, your body and your mind is going to experience intense fear and intense relief. And that relief, because it is so profound,
because your life has been spared, your brain can misinterpret that. as gratitude or as though the captor has shown you a deep kindness. And that becomes very emotionally confusing. Over time, a lot of people report who have experienced this, that the mere absence of violence or even small moments of human decency, they feel like acts of mercy. They feel like this person may have sympathy for them. It feels like this person is human.
And that convinces them that maybe they actually care about you, maybe they care about what you're going through, and maybe, like, there is some kind of redeemable part of them. And that is a very, very critical thing that you want to hold on to. If you are being shown signs of kindness that indicate that somebody could be redeemable, you really want to cling on to that. And if that means trying to bring that out of them more, of course you're going to do that. They're not the exact same thing, but a lot of people will show these links between Stockholm Syndrome and trauma bonding. And they say they're quite similar. Think of a trauma bond. A trauma bond is just a broader concept entirely. It's that kind of
addictive emotional roller coaster that we have with a toxic partner or family member or friend where the highs really make you stay despite the lows. There's that intermittent reinforcement there that makes you feel compelled to be with them or be around them. Stockholm syndrome is a very specific type of trauma bond that happens very quickly during an extreme crisis. Researchers from the University of British Columbia published an article in 1993, which found that emotional attachment can be especially strong when there is a power imbalance. And when that power imbalance seems to dictate everything that happens to somebody, but also involves this intermittent like kindness and then cruelty. The bond is not created on the kindness alone, and it's not created on the fear alone.
It is created by the cycle between those two things. Threat and then relief. Threat and then relief. Victims remain hopeful for the kind moments to keep emerging. They remain unsure when they will, and that further complicates any effort to escape or resist, because they are perhaps waiting for the right time that they could do this, or they're still hopeful that this person may bestow one final, act of kindness and let them go. This also relates to isolation and that and dependency and the fact that
in these kinds of situations, it's kind of just the people in the room. There's no outside input. It is typically one person and their captor or a couple of people and their captors. In a hostage situation, somebody's well-being, the person's well-being and their survival is entirely dependent on the captor. food, water, access to the bathroom, sleep, physical safety, all of that is controlled by the person holding them captive. The captor becomes both the source of terror and also the gatekeeper of survival. And so when you have basically zero agency, the mind does strange things. The mind tries to create agency, maybe by thinking, hey, I was kinder to them today. I showed sympathy for them, and they treated me this way. Therefore, maybe something I do.
is influencing the outcome. Maybe my actions can change what is happening to me. I can influence this. I do have agency. And that alone feels so hopeful and so alluring that somebody might start to mimic a relationship with somebody or mimic an emotional bond with someone because it seems useful and because it gives them a sense that they can change what is happening to them. There is a very relevant theory here from somebody called Jennifer Freed, and it's her work on betrayal trauma theory. Freed proposed that in these kinds of relationships, the mind may engage in what she calls betrayal blindness. This doesn't necessarily mean the person is unaware of what is happening, but rather that their awareness is limited, fragmented, or pushed out of their immediate conscious focus.
This can involve forgetting, minimizing, or reinterpreting harmful behavior in ways that allow the relationship to continue because the relationship now feels like the only place where somebody is safe. If acknowledging the full reality of the harm would threaten access to care, protection, basic needs, then maintaining the relationship can take priority over fully processing the portrayal or thinking of a way out. This is especially evident in childhood abuse where a child is entirely dependent on their caregiver for safety, their attachment, for survival. In those situations, recognizing a caregiver as dangerous can be so overwhelming and just simply not a reality that the child can accept because then they would have no one. So they do things to instead preserve a sense of trust or
attachment, even if that means distorting or suppressing certain aspects of their experience. That same underlining, you know, dynamic can also apply in coercive, situations in captivity situations, trafficking situations or abusive situations. It is a complex form of psychological adaptation. There is some incredibly interesting research that shows us the underlying mechanism behind this. Researches in New York conducted a study in 2010, which basically looked at a set of infant rats. And infant rats, when they're very young, very much like children, you know, rely on their mothers for everything, for warmth, for feeding for just, survival, and they actually learn to recognize and approach their mother largely through smell
because they can't see. What they found was that in early life, rat pups, as they're called, can actually develop a preference for their maternal odor, the smell of their mother, even if that odor has been paired with a mild electric shock. So even if that association harms them. And researchers have argued that this makes developmental sense. For a very young animal, staying close to the caregiver is so essential for survival that the attachment system can override the ordinary avoidance learning that would usually take place and say, avoid this person, avoid this thing, it's going to hurt you, it is hurting you. In other words, the infant rat's brain is biased towards staying close to the caregiver because separation may be even more dangerous
than the distress associated with staying with them. And we can see a lot of parallels to captive situations, abusive situations, coercive situations, and obviously in people that aren't children. Because when you're at that stage where like somebody is providing everything for you, you are basically a child, right? Like when you're a kid, your parents decide when you get fed, when you go to bed, everything about your day, when you are stripped of all agency and somebody is doing all those things for you. It's a very similar emotional and mental state to be in. What's really important to understand is that these responses are often not conscious, right? They're not deliberate.
It's not a decision to sit there and think, maybe I'll bond with this person. Maybe I'll form a deep relationship with them that's going to be very confusing if this ever comes to an end. You know, maybe I should, maybe I should do this or that. Like it's not like somebody is sitting there thinking through every single part of this and what it means for them. Maybe they're thinking of it in a strategic sense, but a lot of the time it's automatic and it's instinctual. Again, this really comes down to our nervous system that often acts in a way beyond our complete conscious thought. The decision is happening fast. It's happening automatically. And what people think after the fact doesn't matter as long as there is an after the fact, as long as somebody survives.
So what happens then? You know, what would happen when somebody is released? when, you know, the person who has done this to them goes to prison or dies or is arrested, do they feel sympathy? Does that sympathy continue? You know, do they want to be with that person? Like, what actually happens? What a lot of FBI interviewers and research has found is that a lot of the time there is this weird reality, like this is weird, like vacuum space between when somebody is rescued or, or something. survives a situation like this, and when they kind of come back to themselves, that is really, really confusing. They find that a lot of, specifically their research is on hostages. So hostages really struggle to recall exactly what happened. They struggle to recall the exact nature of their
那么接下来会发生什么呢？你知道的，当某人被释放后会发生什么？当你知道对他们做出这种事的人入狱、死去或被捕时，他们会感到同情吗？这种同情会持续下去吗？你知道的，他们还想和那个人在一起吗？这到底是怎么回事？许多联邦调查局（FBI）采访人员和研究人员发现，很多时候存在一种奇怪的现实，就像是一个真空地带，介于某人被营救或者经历类似情况并幸存下来，到他们真正恢复自我之间，这个过程真的非常非常令人困惑。他们发现，特别是他们的研究对象是人质。因此人质很难准确回忆起究竟发生了什么。他们很难回忆起他们
appeasement or their experiences, mainly because we know that trauma can affect memory and the ability to describe events clearly. Stress and trauma influence how memory consolidation takes place. Now, sometimes stress can create something called a flashbulb memory, which is like a very strong memory that's almost like a photograph. Everything is very clear. Everything is, you know, memorable. Other times, though, it creates something called dissociative amnesia, where the mind literally blocks certain memories from coming up to the surface or from being consolidated in the first place. causing these gaps, causing these blackout moments. This diagnosis of dissociative amnesia is a little bit controversial. I think there are some researchers out there who would say it's not real. But we do know that memory loss in the face of trauma does happen,
顺从或经历的确切性质，主要是因为我们知道创伤会影响记忆以及清晰描述事件的能力。压力和创伤会影响记忆巩固的过程。现在，有时压力会产生一种叫做闪光灯记忆的东西，这就像是一种非常深刻的记忆，几乎就像一张照片。一切都非常清晰。一切都是，你知道的，令人难忘的。然而，有时它会产生一种叫做解离性失忆的症候群，大脑会字面意义上阻止某些记忆浮出水面，或者在一开始就被巩固。这导致了这些空白，导致了这些大脑空白的时刻。这种解离性失忆的诊断有点争议。我认为有些研究人员会说它并不是真实的。但我们确实知道，面对创伤时记忆丧失确实会发生，
especially if that trauma is very severe, comes upon us very quickly, and it's just incredibly out of the ordinary. There's no narrative, there's no way to understand it. It's such a rare experience that our brain doesn't really have a story to tell us about it. In terms of how long it takes for people to break their appeasement reaction or their Stockholm syndrome, some never do. Some never, never see their feelings or their reaction to their captor diminish. This is really interesting for psychiatrists because some people may say they no longer have these feelings
特别是如果这种创伤非常严重、来得非常快，而且极其反常。没有故事剧本，没有办法去理解它。这是一种如此罕见的经历，以至于我们的大脑其实并没有一个可以讲述给我们的故事。关于人们需要多长时间才能打破他们的顺从反应或斯德哥尔摩综合征，有些人永远做不到。有些人永远、永远不会看到他们对挟持者的感情或反应减弱。这对于精神病学家来说非常有趣，因为有些人可能会说他们不再有这些感情
or this sympathy or this loyalty towards the person who's held them captive or harmed them. They'll say what they think people expect them to say, which is, I hate this person, I wish them harm, they're evil, but when they're really pushed or tricked, like they do still kind of slip up. And there's these moments where they will defend them, where it seems that these beliefs carry over because they were at one point really important for survival. It's difficult to disentangle what you felt once with what you feel now, with what is expected from those around you. And what we do know is that, you know, there might not be a time frame. We can't say, well, it will take six months or 24 months or 36 months to heal from this.
或者对那些囚禁或伤害他们的人怀有这种同情或忠诚。他们会说出他们认为人们期望他们说的话，那就是，我讨厌这个人，我希望他们受到伤害，他们是恶魔，但当他们真的被逼问或套话时，他们还是会露出马脚。会有这样一些时刻，他们会为他们辩护，似乎这些信念一直延续了下来，因为它们在某个时刻对于生存来说真的很重要。很难把曾经的感受与现在的感受分离开来，也很难与周围人对你的期望分离开来。而我们确实知道，你知道的，可能并没有一个具体的时间框架。我们不能说，嗯，需要六个月、二十四个月或三十六个月才能从中治愈。
But it's rarely the flip of a switch. It's not like one moment you have sympathy the next you don't. It's often a gradual reprogramming, very similar to cult reprogramming. Because what you're really having to grapple with is, you know, the fact that you are safe now. Like, I'm safe now. I don't need this attachment or appeasement to keep me. to keep me safe. But when something that out of the ordinary and shocking happens to you, and you can see how quickly life can just be changed in a minute, how strange life can be, how scary life can be, some part of you never feels safe again. And so we'll continue to keep what it sees as a necessary survival skill on the back burner. What's really critical,
但这很少是像按一下开关那样瞬间发生的。这并不是说这一秒你有同情心，下一秒就没有了。这通常是一个逐渐重新编程的过程，非常类似于邪教的洗脑改造。因为你真正需要应付的是，你知道的，你现在已经安全了这一事实。就像，我现在安全了。我不需要这种依恋或顺从来保护我，保护我安全。但是当如此反常和令人震惊的事情发生在你身上，当你看到生活是多么迅速地在一分钟内改变，生活可以是多么陌生，生活可以是多么可怕时，你的一部分永远不会再感到安全。因此，它会继续保留它视为什么是必要的生存技能。真正至关重要的是，
and as I said, it's the same for cult deep programming, is not to believe, or shame the person. You have to be very curious. You have to be accepting. You have to really be open-minded. Because a big part of why Stockholm syndrome occurs is that, you know, the only person you've shared this life-changing experience with, the only person who can understand what you went through is your captor, is the person who did this to you. You know, that's the only other person who was probably in that room. And this person also likely told you that no one would believe you, no one would understand you. No one would protect you the way that they did. So opening up leaves somebody insanely vulnerable to those things being proven true. It's such a vulnerable place to be like,
正如我所说，邪教深度洗脑改造也是如此，就是不要去批判或羞辱这个人。你必须充满好奇心。你必须具有包容性。你必须真正思想开明。因为斯德哥尔摩综合征之所以会发生，很大一部分原因是，你知道的，你唯一一个分享过这种改变命运经历的人，唯一一个能理解你经历的人就是你的挟持者，就是对你做这件事的人。你知道的，那是当时可能在这个房间里的另一个人。而这个人很可能也对你说过，没有人会相信你，没有人会理解你。没有人会像他们那样保护你。所以向外敞开心扉会让人极其脆弱，担心那些说法被证明是真的。处于这样一个脆弱的境地，就好像，
I feel this confusing way. And for somebody to be like, oh my God, how could you feel that way? Or like, oh my God, that's ridiculous. Or like, what are you talking about? Suddenly it's like, well, of course now I can't talk to anybody. The only person who would understand this is the person who created this reaction in me. It kind of draws people back into the situation when they feel shamed for it or feel like people think they've done the wrong thing. There is actually a specific kind of psychologist who specializes in cult deprogramming and in what we call exit counseling. And it's very, very rare because Stockholm syndrome is very, very rare. But again, it doesn't focus on trying to make somebody realize that they were crazy or that they should be ashamed.
我有着这种混乱的感受。而当有人说，哦天哪，你怎么能有这种感觉？或者说，哦天哪，这太荒谬了。或者说，你在说什么呢？突然之间就像是，好吧，那我当然不能跟任何人说话了。唯一能理解这一点的人，就是那个在我身上制造出这种反应的人。当人们因为这种感受而感到羞耻，或者觉得别人认为自己做了错事时，这实际上会把人们重新拉回那种境地中。实际上有一种特定类型的心理学家，他们专门研究邪教深度洗脑改造以及我们称之为退出辅导的领域。这非常非常罕见，因为斯德哥尔摩综合征本身就非常非常罕见。但同样，它不侧重于试图让人意识到他们当时疯了或者他们应该感到羞耻，
or that this person is awful, it's really a kind of psychoeducation that says, you know, well, of course that would be your reaction. Of course, this is how your mind processed this. This is just how your brain experienced and responded to danger to keep you safe. So there's no shame. You're not some freak. You're not some, you know, there's not anything wrong with you. This is a very specific, unique, rare situation to be in that's still unexplored, but that we know our brain has counterintuitive and strange reactions to. Again, your brain doesn't care if you're fulfilled, doesn't care if you're happy, it just cares that you're alive.
或者这个人很糟糕，它实际上是一种心理教育，告诉你，你知道的，好吧，那当然会是你的反应。当然，这就是你的大脑处理这件事的方式。这只是你的大脑为了保护你安全而经历和应对危险的方式。所以没有羞耻。你不是什么怪胎，你不是什么，你知道的，你身上没有任何毛病。这是一种非常具体、独特、罕见的处境，目前尚未被完全探索，但我们知道大脑对它有着反直觉且奇怪的反应。再说一次，你的大脑不在乎你是否感到充实，不在乎你是否快乐，它只在乎你还活着。
And this is one of the ways that it does that. So that, my friends, is our full episode on Stockholm Syndrome. I know I mentioned cult deprogramming, and I want to go into it more. So I want to let you know we're going to do a full episode on that very, very soon. It bears a lot of similarities to exit counseling for some. with Stockholm Syndrome. So if you're very interested in this kind of element of things and specifically in forensic psychology, do not worry. That is coming to you soon. Thank you, as always, to our research at Libby Cobb for her assistance with this episode. Make sure that you check out an episode on Netflix.
这也是它做到这一点的途径之一。所以，我的朋友们，这就是我们关于斯德哥尔摩综合征的完整一集。我知道我提到了邪教洗脑改造，我想更深入地探讨它。所以我想让你们知道，我们很快就会推出一集专门关于这个主题的完整节目。对于某些患有斯德哥尔摩综合征的人来说，它与退出辅导有很多相似之处。所以，如果你对这方面的元素特别感兴趣，尤其是法医心理学，请不要担心。这很快就会带给你们。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员莉比·科布（Libby Cobb）对本期节目的协助。确保你们去看看Netflix上的一集节目。
If you haven't already, that is right. We are now on Netflix. Not this episode, though, because this is a bonus episode that is only audio. Hence why these episodes sometimes sound a little bit stranger because I guess where I am right now I'm literally in my bedroom I'm recording this in bed compared to my beautiful state of the art studio so hence why somebody actually said she was like oh who was it this somebody commented and was like are you using AI to make your voice and I was like no I just am doing it old school which is kind of ironic but yeah that's why there's a little bit of a quality difference especially today with my voice so if you've made it this thought thank you for bearing with me, leave a little, what's like a Swedish emoji?
如果你还没看的话，没错。我们现在上Netflix了。不过不是这一集，因为这是一集仅有音频的特别番外篇。因此，这就是为什么这些节目有时听起来有点奇怪，因为我想我现在所处的地方，我literally就在我的卧室里，我在床上录音，相比于我那漂亮先进的录音室，所以这就是为什么有人实际上说她就像是，哦，是谁，某人评论说，你是在用AI模仿你的声音吗，我就说，不，我只是在用老派的方法，这其实有点讽刺，但是的，这就是为什么音质会有所不同，特别是今天我的声音，所以如果你听到了这里，谢谢你一直包容我，留一个小小的，什么来着，就像一个瑞典表情符号？
Leave a little meatball down below. If you're listening on Spotify and you have made it this far, I really do appreciate when you listen all the way to the end. And anything else you want to know, hear about, keep in touch with, learn about. You can follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast or Substack, the Psychology of your 20s. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon.
在下方留一个小肉丸吧。如果你在Spotify上收听并且已经听到了这里，当你们一直听到最后时，我真的非常感激。还有任何你想知道的、想听的、想保持联系的、想了解的内容。你可以在Instagram上关注我们，账号是That Psychology Podcast，或者在Substack上关注，The Psychology of your 20s。我们下期再见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。
New school year, same beautiful mess. Good Mom's Bad Choices is back to talk back to school realness. The guilt, the giggles, and the choices no other show is brave enough to admit. Mom Life is calling, and I have my last mother fucking volleyball tournament of Irie's club team volleyball, and I can't wait for the to be over. Because I don't like participating and having to drive far to. and says, shout out to the moms and my mom who made it happen. Listen to Good Mom's Bad Choices from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio
新学期，依旧是美丽的一团糟。“美好妈妈的糟糕选择”回归了，来聊聊开学季的现实。那些内疚、咯咯的笑声，以及其他节目不敢承认的选择。妈妈的生活在召唤，我即将迎来艾莉俱乐部排球队最后一场他妈的排球锦标赛，我已经迫不及待它结束了。因为我不喜欢参与还得开车去很远的地方。在此向妈妈们以及让我得以成行的我妈致敬。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“美好妈妈的糟糕选择”，来自Black Effect播客网络。
app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. We've all been there. We've had seasons that have shaken everything. The question is, what remains when the shaking stops? Hi, I'm Gary Valenzheno. And on my podcast, Unshaken with Gary V, I sit down with amazing personalities and We talk about the seasons that nearly broke them, the lows that carried them to their highs. Listen to Unshaken with Gary V on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们都曾经历过。我们都经历过动摇一切的时期。问题是，当动摇停止时，什么留了下来？嗨，我是加里·瓦伦泽诺（Gary Valenzheno）。在我的播客节目《加里·V的坚定不移》（Unshaken with Gary V）中，我与优秀的杰出人物坐在一起，我们聊聊那些差点压垮他们的时期，以及那些将他们带向人生巅峰的低谷。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《加里·V的坚定不移》。
Hi, I'm Dr. James Stout. You might know me as a host of the podcast it could happen here. But I'm hosting a brand new show now called Natural Causes, where we explain how going outside is political, and look at how we can live together with nature and take care of one another in a world that's on fire. You know, we feel uncomfortable saying something like culture in wildlife, but that's what it is. We're going to explain how a tick can make you sick and how a lizard might be able to help you and what mountain lions can teach us about zombie deer. You can see the very faint outline into the Aurora. What a magical place.
嗨，我是詹姆斯·斯托特（James Stout）博士。你可能知道我是播客《可能会发生》（It Could Happen Here）的主持人。但我现在正在主持一个全新节目叫做《自然原因》（Natural Causes），在节目中我们解释了走到户外是如何具有政治性的，并探讨了在一个烈火焚烧的世界中我们如何与自然共存以及如何彼此照顾。你知道的，我们对说“野生动物文化”之类的话感到不舒服，但事实就是如此。我们将解释一只壁虱如何能让你生病，一只蜥蜴如何能帮助你，以及美洲狮能教给我们关于僵尸鹿的什么知识。你可以看到极光非常微弱的轮廓。多么神奇的一个地方。
Listen to natural courses on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. It's everybody's favorite time of year. Girls all over America are spending thousands of dollars at Kendris Scott. Lulu Lemon and going crazy on Revolve. No seriously, guys, it is time for sorority rush. You'll learn about the sex lives of sorority girls. Plus, we'll reveal what frat boys really think about sorority girls. Listen to Dirty Rush on America's number one podcast network Iheart.
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《自然原因》。这是每个人一年中最喜欢的时刻。全美各地的女孩们都在肯德里斯·斯科特（Kendra Scott）和露露柠檬（Lululemon）花费数千亿美元，并在Revolve上疯狂购物。说真的，伙计们，是时候进行姐妹会招新了。你将了解到姐妹会女孩们的性生活，此外，我们还将揭示兄弟会男生对姐妹会女孩的真实看法。在全美第一播客网络Iheart收听《肮脏的招新》（Dirty Rush）。
Follow Dirty Rush and start listening on the free Iheart radio app today. Hey, it's Nora Jones, and my podcast playing along is back with more of my favorite musicians. Check out my newest episode with Phineas. So I went home and I asked Billy if she wanted to sing it. She immediately made it her own thing. You really know how to make me cry when you give me those ocean eyes. I'm scared. So come hang out with us in the studio and listen to playing along on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts.
关注《肮脏的招新》，今天就在免费的Iheart radio应用上开始收听。嘿，我是诺拉·琼斯（Nora Jones），我的播客《随之起舞》（Playing Along）带着更多我最喜爱的音乐家回归了。快来收听我与芬尼斯（Finneas）的最新一集节目。所以我回家问比利她是否想唱这首歌。她立刻把它变成了她自己的风格。当你给我那些海洋之眼时，你真的很懂得如何让我哭泣。我很害怕。所以快来录音室和我们一起闲逛，并在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《随之起舞》。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。